tom curran patriots insider here on the
rich eisen show here on a crazy mixed up
world when uh thursday how are you tom
what's going on
at the moment i'm eating uh tiny little
chocolate covered pretzels with little
holiday sprinkles on them okay they are
incredible was that
was that was that part of belichick's
i'm sorry gift to the media as well did
he give out chocolates to you too tom no
nope nothing like that no he didn't do
anything like that i think he went far
enough the funny thing is rich yes tom
on a scale of one to ten
post-game agitation that was like a
three
i still don't understand why he
apologized for the group
nobody felt bad
so please walk me through
what happened monday when he apologized
for his post-game um shortness
abruptness please walk me through what
that was like with you and your
colleagues who have been covering the
team for so long tom curran please doing
that favor you know he gets on the zoom
bell is you know before i start here
you know you've got the rest of the
audio but basically said that he it
wasn't our fault not your fault
um
that they lost the game
but here's my theory yes
guy i work with phil perry he and i have
been together on the beat for 10 years
and phil is a very diligent hard-working
respectful courteous guy who does
stories that go well and in depth kind
of like i was 15 years ago
so
bill loves phil
and phil asked the first four questions
in the post game
and each one of them bill kind of sent
back and i'm like karch karai
at the next good reference good spike
reference man i like it i like it no
i really think that some of it had to do
with phil now we have people going
somebody got the bill and made him
apologize
i'm like for what it wasn't even bad no
window said something to him or
that was new jonathan or robert i'm like
do you know what his face would look
like if jonathan or robert told him to
apologize after all the things
that he had done in post games
to think that he would no he just felt
bad about
whether it be phil in specific or all of
us in general
he's like yeah you know what whatever
just tell him i'm sorry
that'll catch him that'll catch him my
theory was exactly that it's just a
great life partner seeing your video and
how you have come across and them
wanting to make sure that they've you
you know
you do better or or can be seen in a
light that you should be seen in since
you know she or he sees you in it that's
what that's spoke that's what that
looked like so you thought it might have
been linda holliday no question in my
mind he was just wait
he's been with him since like seven i
know
i don't know
where what was it or wait wait hold on
maybe we just just think it's it's bill
self scouting maybe he's self scouting
what do you think
i think 100 think that look if it was me
sitting there asking those questions i
don't think you would have circled back
and said i'm sorry
[Laughter]
i'm not saying we have a bad
relationship but over the course of time
yes i think that you know there's a
there's plenty in both buckets good
times bad times i wish this kid would
get another job times so
all of that
but with phil i think if everything has
been to the good with phil he actually
thought phil out last year you're not so
on some time he thought phil out because
phil asked some scouting question and
feels like yeah it's a million things
i'm not going to get into that
and then the next day
he comes on his own he goes yeah phil i
mean
sorry about that here's how we do this
on the scout okay and he goes on about
first
he's got a soft spot for this one
reporter is what you're saying he's got
a soft spot yeah the senator phil perry
i want you to have him on he's like the
randy moss of your group like you know
or he's got like the lt or your group
he's a young guy like he's got he's got
a soft spot
he's a zeke moat what is he
no
is he the zeke of the group
he's okay oh okay
okay he's matthew slater
i got it okay
see by the way to all of us this
actually makes sense that makes sense
we were just
we just i i i i knew that was gonna have
to be my first question of you just what
what it was like to the beat writers
who've been around there and done that
that is a cool thing about this job is
to try and
figure out the psychology behind what
the people say whether it's belichick or
matt jones or brady um
because there is so much that goes on
behind the curtain and we do know how
purposeful his words and his times at
the podium are
that
it does become an interpretive dance
where with dan campbell there's no real
interpretation it's all right there
you know but with belichick it's you
know the most successful but also the
most enigmatic and
and discreet team there is so
we get to have people come and say what
do you think can we come up with that
cockamamie ideas we're probably all
wrong anyway well there's another sorry
this week as well uh right from mac
jones apologizing he just won't answer
questions about the colts game anymore
so
what's going on there have we that is
that is bill at the point of a bayonet
saying we're not talking about that game
it wasn't us
we're off it we're done with it because
i think that's one of those games you
know how the berry the football game the
patriots did it a long time ago after
brady's second start many teams have
done it since where they
ceremoniously bury the football to say
that game didn't happen the compatriots
are doing the same thing with the colts
game which is interesting guys
because i think that's what the bills
wanted to do with the patriots game the
bills got shamed the bills at least in
the mind of sean mcdermott beat
themselves in many ways he sat there at
the podium basically saying they didn't
beat us we beat ourselves and that's the
same feeling the patriots have about the
colts colts played well
but the patriots backed themselves up
gave a punt block touchdown up
took a you know had a
red zone pick yeah took a three points
off the board on us they completely
believe yeah colts nice team but they're
not better than us
so that's why they're moving on from
that
i don't know about that though
yeah i know but that's what they think i
know and i i don't blame him for
thinking that i i don't blame him for
thinking that and i i saw
more mistakes than what you just walked
through and i'm sure you you did as well
you know there was also what first play
the second half where where it looked
like
either stevenson got the ball uh
incorrectly or the lineman thought it
was a pass play instead of a run play i
mean
coming out of the out of the locker room
that way in the second half and this is
after a bye
so
obviously these games happen and and we
hadn't seen the patriots play something
like that in quite some time
um
what what about mack jones what what to
read out of that i know you want to bury
it but that fourth quarter
was uh
pretty damn good certainly that throw to
hunter henry out of the outstretched
arms of darius leonard like that's the
good stuff that's what you might need
in january you know on occasion
so he is so amazingly resilient i mean
and we've seen it
all the way through camp from tiny play
to play bounce backs
to bad practice to the next day
unbelievable practice bounce backs to
even in the chargers game remember we've
talked about that rich a couple times on
this on this show you were there that
day you watched the game
i took that as a huge game for him in
that for three quarters he played
like a rookie
and like a c-level nfl starter
and in the fourth quarter when they
needed a clinching drive
he was pretty much lights out
so he bounced back in that game i would
imagine that this week
if he
holds true to form
he will play a hell of a lot better than
he did last week
because he always has bounced back but
at some point though
when you've gone through what he's gone
through in the last year
without cease
from alabama
to the draft process beating out cam to
a 17 week regular season at some point i
just say i'm done man i need to just
close my eyes here for a minute
and he doesn't appear to be doing that
so what is the approach for this game
this week do they did they take out that
passing game that they didn't need
um
a couple weeks ago and just throw that
out there i know bill is even joking
about that after the game like yeah we
were talking about like
we could use the passing game in a
couple weeks because we didn't use it
tonight
um
or or what is the sense like that that
three pass night against buffalo
um
is is it right or wrong to say that that
is the way that the patriots look at mac
jones when it comes down to winning
football games i i i think it's the way
that the patriots played depending on
all circumstances and the circumstances
of the weather so but you hear the
you know the way they look at the bills
it's not how they look at mack jones
it's how they look at the bills and if
they say well
they kind of got a soft underbelly there
let's throw some body shots
then they'll do that but if they had a
weak chin and they thought that they
needed to hit up high and they wanted to
throw they would they would let mac do
that i think it has much less to do with
the nature of the quarterback than it
does the nature of the opponent
and this week i just don't know how
buffalo can magically wave a wand
and be better in the front seven against
the run
you know it's so if i were the patriots
i would approach it exactly the same way
as they did the the last time around
and until they stop it
keep hammering it
but what'll be interesting is they're
kind of forced to approach that way as
well
because nelson aguilera's got a
concussion nikhil harry's got a hip
injury and kendrick bourne is in covert
protocols he could be out by then
but that's your wide receiver room
except for jacoby myers
what is with what is the wide receiver
room like how
you know i i i don't know the end of the
hall
i know
i i i just
right it is it is what would you say
it's the
weakest link on this team would you say
that or is that
unfair
go forward
what is it oh boy it's uh
they're not gonna they're not gonna give
you a plus work
they're gonna give you a lot of 78s to
81s
okay c
plus b
needs improvement
there's never but they're never going to
give you a 67 either
you know
they're just not going to turn that test
in and you have to go what were you
doing
that's their feeling is 78 to 81.
and that's the interesting thing about
this offense is a lot of those skill
positions are populated by guys like
that there is no gronk
there is no edelman
there's no james white who could
occasionally turn in a 93 for you they
don't have guys who can turn in a days
so you need everybody to to make sure
that they have their 78 or above well
i'll tell you what i think i think that
kid's stealing
i do i think it's great no no i i really
do uh i i think that kid stevenson can
though right and harris
i i i mean the way that he hops in the
hole sometimes the way that he avoids
contact he is really talented and and
that's that's the question is like which
team
[Music]
will make the patriots throw to beat him
which team is going to put it on matt
jones in a january
cold day or a january crucible on the
road which team is going to do that
which team is going to force the
patriots to have to do that
and that's why i keep returning to the
cults a little bit because that's what
they did
that's what they did yeah but i don't
think but the colts can't run and hide
the way kansas city can okay then that's
well i i yes in theory that's another
one of those obviously um
because you know the chargers could uh
against the certain teams but not new
england i mean that's why i just got i'm
trying to you know sort of hunt and peck
here's
kansas city could just like you know the
colts were aided by the patriots kansas
city could go touchdown touchdown
touchdown on you
and you really didn't even do anything
wrong
you down 21 nothing i mean we've seen
him do that in the playoffs right but so
that would be a team that that would put
the onus on
the patriots to say okay well we came in
one to be balanced but we got thrown out
but i really don't think that there's a
lot about mac jones game that would make
me say
okay party's over i'm gonna go you know
take the decorations down
i still think he has enough
that he could
perform in a desperate you gotta throw
it 55 times game i really do
well i mean again the kids played in big
games before i mean he just has he's
played in big games he's played in
championship games he's a self-made kid
he's taken coaching clearly very well
you know um and um
it just was
can't win that's why i i just basically
you know racked that one up to the can't
win them all category like new england
wasn't going to win out you know and
that but that's what makes this weekend
so big
you know because you can knock him out
are you happy that until one o'clock or
would you rather it be a prime time or a
four no i like it at once sometimes
sometimes man you got to serve some
filet mignon for breakfast you know
sometimes it's what you got to do
but it would be a little colder at night
though you got to get your steak in your
eggs you know i know but these guys are
these guys are built for the cold well
actually matt jones will see all right
they already had an element game i like
crystal clear warm i don't even know
what the weather is but well we we
talked about it yesterday it's 40
degrees
partly cloudy you know that's it that's
it that's all you're gonna get so i'm
i'm with you too hey before i let you go
i'll put you on the spot it's festivus
you know we're airing of grievances you
got anything you want to air for
grievance either sports-wise or just you
know
the world tom oh you're from new england
you must have a grievance
i do but i'm reading a book uh it's
called untethered soul and i have to
read this book every once in a while
when i'm starting to get agitated
very helpful i have a stack of like
these self-help books okay where you got
to you have to shut up the little thing
in your brain that's constantly chirping
at you
so as a result i have no festivus
grievances because i've asked that guy
to shut up
huh
do you think that's what belichick's
reading now too tom maybe that's it
[Laughter]
friends and influence people
um maybe maybe maybe bill's reading
untethered soul too and that's what he's
saying
it came out in 2007 it's a very simple
book it's pretty helpful right okay we
all have that little guy who just never
shuts up
somebody goes past you in traffic then
they cut back in and you just what is he
doing you know what how would he like me
on his bumper how would he like it make
him
and then you're like what are you doing
that for that's right untethered soul i
got it the journey beyond yourself
that's what's going on it's it's called
the journey beyond yourself the
untethered soul the journey beyond
yourself i know people i roll with this
stuff i do but
anything that can make you a little bit
better more at peace every day ain't
nothing wrong with that you'll be more
fun around the family unless you're a
tethered soul do you want to be a
tethered soul
on christmas morning if you do go ahead
be as tethered as you want to be but
you're going to be not fun to be around
yeah we just looked it up the uh the
audiobook version is read by bill
belichick so yep that's it
are you audio or hard copy tom he's a
hard cop i'm a kindle guy come on
oh very good that's old school in a way
too okay very good well you'll be
perfect for the los angeles super bowl
if you make it tom so that'll be perfect
it'll be perfect thank you i'll see you
out there i hope so yeah i hope you'll
see me no doubt it's good to see you tom
curran or good to chat with you you be
we'll have a happy holiday with you and
your family all right thanks for always
having me thanks for making me happy be
part of this and i appreciate it always
right back at you at tom e curran on
twitter follow him i do
fun follow the best
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here